let's think a little bit about the
volume of a cone so a cone would have a
circular base where I guess depends on
how you want to draw it you think of
like a conical hat of some kind it would
have a circle as a base and that would
come to some point so it looks something
like that this you could consider this
to be a cone just like that or you can
make it upside down if you're thinking
of an ice-cream cone so it might look
something like that that's the top of it
and then it comes down like this this
also is kind of those disposable cups of
water you might see it's some water
coolers and the important things that we
need to think about when we want to know
about the volume of a cone is we will
definitely want to know the radius of
the base we definitely want to know the
radius of the base so that's the radius
of the base or here it's the radius of
the top part you definitely want to know
that radius and you want to know the
height of the cone you want to know the
height of the cone so let's call that H
right over here you could call this
distance right over here H and the
formula for the volume of a cone and
it's interesting because it's close to
the formula for the volume of a cylinder
in a very clean way which is somewhat
surprising and that's what's neat about
a lot of this three-dimensional geometry
is that it's not as messy as you would
think it would be it is the area of the
base well what's the area of the base
well that's going to be the area of the
base is going to be PI R squared it's
going to be PI R squared times the
height times the height and if you just
multiply the height times PI R squared
that would give you the volume of the
entire of an entire cylinder that looks
something like that
so this would give you this entire
volume that looks that looks of the
figure that looks like this where it's
center of the top is the tip right over
here so if I just left it as PI R
squared H or H times PI R squared so the
volume of this entire can this entire
cylinder but if you just want the cone
it's one-third of that it is one-third
of that and that's what I mean when I
say
it's surprisingly clean that this cone
right over here is one-third the volume
of this cylinder that is essentially you
can kind of think of the cylinder as
bounding around it or if you wanted to
rewrite this you could write this as 1/3
times pi or PI over 3 times H R squared
however you want to view it the easy way
I remember it for me the volume of a
cylinder is very intuitive you take the
area of the base and then you multiply
that times the height and so a volume of
a cone is just 1/3 of that it's just 1/3
the volume of the bounding cylinder is
one way to think about it
let's just apply these numbers just to
make sure that that it makes sense to us
so let's say that this is some type of a
conical glass the types that you might
see the watercooler and let's say that
we're told that it holds so this thing
holds 131 cubic centimeters of water and
let's say that we're also told that it's
height
we're told that it's height right over
here you only do that in a different
color we're told that the height of this
cone is 5 centimeters and so given that
if what is roughly the radius of the top
of this glass let's just say to the
nearest tenth of a centimeter well we
just once again have to apply the
formula the volume which is 131 cubic
centimeters is going to be equal to 1/3
times pi times the height which is five
centimeters five centimeters times the
radius squared times the radius squared
or if we wanted to solve for the radius
squared we could just divide both sides
by all of this business and we would get
radius squared radius squared is equal
to 131 centimeters school to the third
all right 131 cubic centimeters I should
say you divide by 1/3 that's the same
thing as multiplying by 3 and then of
course you're going to divide by PI and
you're going to divide by 5 centimeters
5
centimetres now let's see if we can
clean this up centimeters will cancel
out with one of these centimeters so you
left just be left with square
centimeters only in the numerator and so
this is going to be an N to solve for R
we could take the square root of both
sides so we could say that our R is
going to be equal to the square root of
three times one thirty one is 393 over
five PI over five PI so that's this part
right over here and the square root once
again remember we can treat units just
like algebraic quantities the square
root of centimeter squared well that's
just going to be centimeters which is
nice because we want our units in
centimeters so let's get our calculator
out to actually calculate this kind of
messy expression turn it on C square
root of 393 divided by five times pi
five times pi is equal to five I was
pretty close so to the nearest it's it's
pretty much five centimeters so this is
so our radius is approximately equal to
five centimeters at least in this
example